when you listen to Kanye talk he doesn't  he can't articulate his opinions and  that's my opinion even though Kanye's a  brilliant artist I just don't think  publicly speaking on these subjects in a  long-form podcast is his specialty it  seems like he almost wants to get  canceled he was wearing a Balenciaga  mask today on the Alex Jones uh pop you  know interview when he was here he was  wearing a Balenciaga jacket people are  getting canceled because they don't  disavow Valencia Balenciaga he's still  wearing it as he's talking about the  most craziest outlandish things that he  knows will get people talking about it  we'll get people riled up some people  are saying that this is a deliberate  suicide of his career  um I think that's also another  possibility here some people are saying  that there's clear you know problems  mentally here who knows I I don't know I  I can't really quantify it I'm just kind  of you know  why is he just shocked at all this to be  honest with you